well I can tell you what works
what doesn't work and I'll tell you one
of the best things I've seen in the
world what works our school feeding
water projects were you dig for Wells
immunization projects basic education
for mothers when you teach mothers how
to read and write I'll tell you when you
do that the population goes down the
gross national product comes up because
the mothers learn about boiling water
they learn about breastfeeding and learn
about nutrition they learn about how to
start their own businesses which leads
into micro and our fries micro
microcredit which is probably one of the
best ways to get people on their feet
and you can take people if you put those
kinds of programs into a country you
will take people out of poverty school
feeding because it's a real security
issue I'll never forget this man from
Pakistan it was a farmer saying to me a
very poor man I said why do you send
your son to that school that teaches
hate about us about United States and
Western nations he said I'd do that
because I can't feed him I can't pay for
his education I can't pay for his
clothes I can't board him anymore and
the school even though I know it teaches
hate and I don't like to school they do
it all school feeding competes with that
and we get kids back in school because a
lot of the poor especially in rural
areas can't afford to allow their
children to go to school because they
need them to help them in the fields but
when you feed them that's one less mouth
and we feed them with proper nutrition
fortified and i'll tell you it doesn't
world of
good one and and also the other thing
about it it gets women and girls back
into schools when we do school feeding
and I told you about microcredit if you
do all of those things school feeding
basic education water projects
immunization microcredit you'll bring a
country up real quick now we don't do
them all together we should and there's
a lot of problems in the international
community but we're not streamlined
without organized we don't work together
but when I've seen that that all of
those things work very well they're all
worth Wow and they're all good